this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised
well now there are ways to start on an
average Safari and then there are
magical ways to start on a live Safari
and an elephant calf that is just a few
hours old well I think it's safe to say
we know where that one Falls a very good
afternoon to all of you my name is Jaime
and this afternoon
sebastian is on camera with me and we
are live from Zoomer private game
reserve in the sabi sand in the greater
Kruger National Park area of South
Africa I don't want to take my eyes off
the little one so now that we've got
that out of the way remember you can
send through your questions and your
comments on hashtag Safari Live on
Twitter or alternatively you can ask us
questions in the YouTube chat stream
just once a drink month and they've just
come down for those of you that don't
know we have a camera out of the water
hole here and it has just come down for
a drink it planted its face in the water
it was too adorable for words I didn't
even know they had such flexible hips
and is now desperately trying to have
some food mum they've crossed over onto
the other side of the waterhole and the
good news is is that I can now see the
guests at the lodge going to go on their
game drive which means that we can
quickly nip across the dam wall and
follow it which is what I was waiting
for all excited moms a little bit
unsettled so we're gonna approach this
nice and cautiously but I'm gonna try
and spend as much time as I can with
this little one-off it's just adorable
for words I think they're gonna go and
find a nice feeding spot let's do this
backwards quickie I'm gonna go find a
nice feeding spot in the shade they
might even go and have a little bit of a
sleep I'm hoping that might be the case
cuz they've got such a brand-new herd
member and this is what's so special
about elephants is that the entire herd
will band around the little one and make
sure that it is safe and protected and
the fact that it needs a little bit more
extra sleep then they do will mean that
they take care of it they'll all stop
they'll guarded they'll give it some
shade if necessary Oh
too sweet just a couple of hours old
as we catch up to this little elephant
there are several people out this
afternoon Sydney is one of them and he's
going to tell you what his plans are
a very very good afternoon and welcome
to the beginning of the afternoon Safari
I am Sydney femoral mucosa and I'm
travelling with Sansa with my camera
operator we are going to be looking for
the Lions this afternoon hopefully we
will find them sleeping somewhere and
for your questions and comments you can
follow us on Twitter hashtag safari live
you can also follow us on YouTube chat
stream
for the Sun is very much hotter this
afternoon which is a very nice weather
in order to ground the predator such as
the cats they don't room around a lot
when the Sun is strong like these
chances of seeing the animals who has
been spotted this morning are very much
hi
so I hear this morning there has been a
couple of sightings lion sightings and
some leopard sightings so now let's go
to my other colleague so we are going
now to the Masai Mara where James is
just about to depart good afternoon
everybody and welcome to the same that
the sunset Safari I am in the Masai Mara
in East Africa in Kenya and we are
sitting with this Asajj tree pride and
they of course are having themselves a
good Sunday's news my name is James
Henry please ask us any question you'd
like to using hashtags for life on
Twitter or of course the YouTube chat
stream on camera today we have got manu
el bundy tore a cut sir there he is
making noises and over there we've got
kinky tail she's lying in the grass she
is the most recognizable lion in the
Sahara tree pride they are obviously not
doing an enormous amount right now but
we're pretty sure that there are young
cubs in this riverbed just below where
they're having the snooze so hopefully
they will pop out at some stage we also
have heard reports of a cheetah not too
far from here Manu will point the camera
sort of vaguely in that direction and
we'll head towards there I think while
these chaps sleep they focus of course
it's going to be on these lions because
we have our TV show later on today so I
think we'll probably stay with them for
the duration of the TV show if there are
some strange communications we do have
some strange communications issues with
the final control at Juma but they seem
to be okay at the moment so just be
patient with us there let's go back to
Juma now where Jamie is with an Ellie
we're not going to be able to follow
that little one as much as we were
hoping we could they're very very
unsettled to this afternoon I think
perhaps that females birth has
caused a bit of upset in the herd
remember how I said they're very
protective over their little ones even
if it's not their own baby and that one
female on the left gave us a very stern
look as we made our way closer so we're
just gonna sit here nice and still we're
gonna wait for the female with the baby
to come to us I think it's actually
having a nap
at this point they've made their way
into the shade and I think that's what
it's doing so you can see some of the
older babies of the herd all settled
down around the tempo a thicket that
one's throwing its trunk around you're
trying to grab some sand after the last
few cloudy very cold days it has now
heated up quite nicely there's no land
up to the wind but in the Sun it's
probably what sit around about 29
degrees centigrade okay and far away
it's okay nico nico viewer that tiny
tiny little baby that you saw earlier
you want to know how much it weighs it
weighs around about a hundred kilograms
believe it or not so over 200 pounds
when baby elephants are born they're
born at around about a hundred kilograms
so even though this thing looks minut it
is actually I mean it's the baby of a
the largest land mammal on the planet
it's tiny in comparison to them but not
quite as tiny as you might expect it to
be a big girl if you have a look at this
elephants you can see the deep
indentations around her forward that's
indicative of age in an elephant like
this so she's quite an old female you
can see her skin starting to hang around
her hip bones around her spine so I
would guess she definitely over 40 I
would probably put her even older than
that so one of the senior members of the
herd if not the senior member if not the
matriarch
I'm moving slowly we just have to be
patient in this situation if we
reposition now if we try and see that
baby again they're going to get very
upset with us there it is it's between
the legs there of the of the one
dust-bathing here we go
backing up big girl
I'm backing up it's okay it's alright
here we go
whoopsie what a reverse straight Seb not
into a tree
it's alright big girl here we go
I stop here is that okay is that Alright
unfortunately my car's making some very
peculiar sounds so in that situation I
probably could have stayed where we were
and we would probably have been
absolutely fine but the way in which she
approached it you can see her body
language is unsettled it's okay it's
alright
okay now talking to her has absolutely
no real impact on how she experiences
the situation but they do respond to
tone so by talking low and calm it's
just an extra way of trying to
de-escalate the situation right I'm
going to take my foot off the brake now
Seb sorry I was with my right leg was
slightly slightly tense there so he
probably would have been fine to stay
where we were but I didn't want to get
it to the point where she was very close
to us because she did approach in a very
determined way and what she's doing is
putting herself between us and the tiny
baby which is exactly what we spoke
about and in the shade as well maybe she
just wanted the shade no I don't think
so I think there was a degree of
discomfort there now one thing that I
was not looking at was whether or not
she was flapping her ears because
contrary to what people think when they
see elephants that is not a sign of
aggression and that's to answer Joshua's
question about why elephants move their
ears all the time on a hot day like
today that is their way of cooling down
so it's basically an internal cooling
system there's the baby there say if
it's popped out so it was suckling from
them so it's a sort of an internal
cooling system the skin is quite thin
and a packed full of inside underneath
is packed full of capillaries sweet and
the blood flow is very close to the
surface so they move there they move
their ears which is something the salons
gonna have to learn to do because it's
not quite at that point yet and they
move their ears to create airflow over
the ears that cools down the skin which
cools down the blood which then
circulates to the rest of the elephant's
body covered in dust now I think it's
put its face in the dirt Cole 6 yes
potentially a car horn could scare
elephants off it could do the exact
opposite and actually provoke them so
loud surprising noise like that could
have worked but really it was for me to
back out of her space rather than trying
to scare her off in any way she was
doing exactly what she should which is
protecting her family and I noticed they
were unsettled even when they were at
the water's edge so it was just for us
to back away and to give her a little
bit of space rather than the other way
around see how she stayed even though
the rest of the herd have moved now it's
all right
so we could we could have I mean we've
actually disconnected all of the car
horns given what happened to us once
during a TV show going into an ad break
when it decided to have a mind of its
own and just blare at us during an
actual TV show yes there was a wonderful
time going into ad break good job the
elephant's body language is a very very
important part of reading them so while
you don't have to look at the flapping
ears you do have to look at the ears
occasionally now ears out and head up is
an indication of an unsettled elephant
as well as very stiff tail that is the
tail is the best indicator of mood now
these elephants tails haven't really
been swaying there that's a good example
of a nervous elephant now we were okay
again because we're catching up with our
family hey boy
and you'll notice that there's other
vehicles of making their way in as well
so what we also didn't want to do was be
in a position where they felt sandwiched
between the two of us I had a feeling
they've been trying to call me
but Saul so I think what provoked her
and why the other vehicles are fine with
them is the very strange sound that our
vehicle is currently making Jigar is and
her name is ji ji ji a the car that I'm
driving she doesn't sound very good
she's making some very peculiar whining
sounds and I think that might also have
exacerbated the problem so what I'm
gonna do is I'm actually gonna take the
vehicle back quickly to see if I can
catch the mechanic so while we do I'm
going to race off in that direction I'm
going to send you across to Tristan
who's been racing in the opposite
direction towards clan armor well we are
racing the opposite that where we raced
in the opposite direction we're not
racing anymore as you can see we did
stationary now theoretically we're
exactly where we left Kalama this
afternoon and I mean this morning and
she's supposed to be here but I don't
see any sign of her so you kind of have
to look around a little bit but as Jerry
mentioned my name is Justin on camera
but Craig he's a warm welcome to Rusty
and I hope that you are going to enjoy
your afternoon with us now theoretically
she's supposed to be inside of this
grass he toughed on my left hand side
this is what I'm told the Jackie and
Sharla and Lauren spent the day here and
they said that she hasn't moved but I
don't find a lipid inside there I've
just looked now to try and see but I
don't see her unless I'm just looking in
the complete wrong tuft at the moment
which is not a good thing at all so I'm
just gonna try and see if I can find
some sort of sign up here here it will
just do a little kind of bypass and just
try and check what's going on now she
could be just lying somewhere a slightly
different I think the guys said that she
hasn't moved and now I know for a fact
that in terms of not moving she should
then theoretically be inside here so I'm
just trying to see it is a wall of grass
and so maybe just maybe she's curled up
in there but I don't see any spots at
all or any sign of a little face poking
out and I would expect her to have
lifted a head or her ears at some point
now driven around the other side as well
see anything inside there either so mm
I'm a little bit kind of skeptical that
she maybe maybe just did a little runner
and no one actually even noticed her
moving up the backside of this grassy
kind of area because I don't see any
kind of signs of her and normally with
her she's quite kind of watchful so as
soon as she sees a car she kind of pokes
her head up to see what's going on and I
haven't seen any sort of movement like
that and I'm trying to peer into it I
might be wrong she might be lying right
here and we just can't see her which
would then kind of show how camouflaged
she can be but I somehow don't think so
if I'm honest might be wrong there this
chick I hope she hasn't moved because
that will be a bit tricky to find her
then
Reimer no not necessarily you know she's
waiting for moms her instinct will her
kind of way of doing things is to just
sit still and wait and hope that mom is
you know comes around and so you find it
with cubs they sometimes do sit in the
same spot particularly if it's quite
warm and hot then you'll find that they
will just kind of take it easy in the
same area but what I am surprised about
is the spot she's chosen that's what I
am surprised about this is not the
greatest of the spots for a little lipid
to sleep in now it looks like she was
lying all over here but I don't see any
sign of her Craig do you see anything no
I don't see a lipid inside yeah oh there
she is right there
ah so she's not in the grass at all I've
now spot to do she's really in front of
us sorry Craig I'll move us now but I
just got to be a bit careful so she's
sitting at probably thinking what are
these two doing driving around like
clowns and she's sitting in the quarry
thicket over there anyway let's try and
this reposition Craig so he doesn't have
this quarry Bush in his face is a quarry
right yeah that's hitting Craig so let's
not get Craig all tangled up Greggy I'm
going to move you round now
surprised it didn't see her I was just I
suppose when you're not looking in the
right direction this is what happens
right now I'm going to just reposition
and find myself a little bit but of a
better spot and so while I do that let's
send you back across to James who's on
the search for a different kind of
spotted cat one that is a lot faster
what we are doing while Justin gets
himself a little bit of a spot is trying
to find a cheetah we lift the sausages
we will go back there as the Sun starts
to set but we are told and have seen
evidence of mysterion the cheetah
cheetah race move called the cheetah is
female cheetah and two little Cubs now
she's somewhere around here we've had
three or four reports we have an Ascari
called Elvis with us he is not singing
us a song but he is going to try and
help us find the cheetah which
apparently was around here somewhere
next to this fig tree that looks like a
giraffe he doesn't look like a giraffe
from here but from a distance it really
does I thought it was a fig tree with a
giraffe underneath it and Truman who
said no no that is the fig tree with the
Juara you know that looks like a giraffe
they're just very good now what we need
to do from here
it's scan because apparently underneath
one of these Vallon eyeties trees or
deserts date part desert date trees we
will find the Sirian the shuttle
do you want to see this cheetah please
Monsieur and the cheetah shows your face
there's a Tippi you see the tepee
monoterpenes it's not appear to be alarm
calling to anything let's carry on
they're a couple of termite mounds that
she might just be lying behind yeah Roxy
you're absolutely right the trees are
beautiful here we got up the way right I
was giving a few directions from the
back which is useful because I don't
know what I'm doing in this particular
area how about our rocks here it is the
most stunning afternoon we came out
early because we were terrified a that
we wouldn't find the sausage tree pride
and be that it would rain again and we
wanted to be in position such that if a
storm came through here we'd be safe and
with an animal but it's turned into the
most glorious afternoon it's a lovely
sort of balmy I guess round about 29
degrees I'm told which is 84 degrees
Fahrenheit odd this is very pleasant and
the place is just the most magical color
a couple of nasty rocks around here
she'll definitely be lying in the shade
somewhere and so all we have to do is
find the right bit of shade and given
that there isn't a massive amount of
shade around here it shouldn't present
too much of a difficulty unless of
course she's gone back to her Cubs now
apparently they're in a den somewhere
around here someone else lurking in the
shelter of a bush is Columba the
Huntress oh yes we've got little amber
now who's sitting under a quarry but you
made me think that you disappeared what
you were lying right there
I just opened my eyes I would have kind
of seen her quite easy sir she had been
a snake in the grass she will have
probably bitten me and you know
unfortunately unfortunately rather we
eventually spotted her before we try to
move up too far but I'm sure she's
highly highly sort of bored at this
stage I don't think she's going to be
very happy with mom when mom gets back
mom's going to be in the naughty box
instead of her being in the naughty
corner and this of course mom has food
if mom is food well then you'll find
that the super one will probably be as
boisterous as if and we'll be running
circles around mom as mom takes her to
whatever carcass she might have found
but you know the fact that we're seeing
her being left for the the time period
that she has been over the course of the
last two days there's probably
indicative of her just that Tanya is
starting slowly but surely to increase
periods of time away from Columba in the
hope that Columbus starts to utilize
this time to learn how to hunt him to
find food and to be able to kind of make
it on her own and so I'm not surprised
that this is happening um it's about the
right time that you start to see that
but look at that face
hello little one
oh that's a big stretch she's super cute
isn't she she's been so chilled with us
the past kind of three drives and I've
thoroughly enjoyed spending the time
with her now MGM you're going to ask me
and I'm draw I actually I know this is
ridiculous but I'm drawing a blank as to
what her name means that's right Thank
You Christy sorry I'm getting old cursed
this is what happens but anyway that her
name means mischievious so boisterous
which is now that she's told me exactly
how I would would have remembered it's
hand it's quite fitting because she is
mischievous this little one or she
certainly was very mischievous as a
little cub and as well when moms around
you'll see that she is - she goes all
over the place and runs around like an
absolute hooligan when mom is presence
your goes in circles and she'll be up
and down and on trees and down trees and
looking and chuffing and generally being
a bit of a hooligan so she is a bit
mischievous and when she was tiny she
used to just do anything all the times
used to kind of move around and never
listen to mom and and and that's
basically why I share in the name it's
also well because you guys all voted for
it - I suppose so it was one of three
names that was given to all of you to
vote for to see which one you liked best
and so little fella was what it was
finally settled as nice name though
difficult to say but nice name it's it's
always fine when it's on their own so if
you just say Claire Lama by itself we're
all good but when you add a little Tandy
factor into it that T sound is different
to the T sound of her name and I always
get tongue-tied with it drives James
absolutely mad there was also a stage
where she was being called Clara lumber
which drove James and Scott around the
bend I think both of them were ready to
commit some a mass execution of their
fellow guides at one point because that
was what was being said but obviously we
know it's a llama there's no Allah in
that name so that was all
sorted and the best person in the whole
camp to say Columbus name is Kirsty she
is so talented at saying it she's the
best one like she has a down pat she
knows exactly how to to say it it rolls
off her tongue smooth and in Sookie
she's laughing at me because ghost has a
problem with saying Columbus it always
just comes out in a spew of a's and
elves and ames that just don't really
make the word up at all so it's quite
entertaining kind of listening to curse
try and say it we always have a good
laugh hello little one just call it cab
yes Tandy's covers cruelly forever known
as time these carbon cursed his mind
even when she gets a new one this is
still going to be Tandy's cup but you
can see she's half sleepy bird half
bored I think she's kind of want
something to happen but it's still a bit
warm and windy and she knows that we're
here and we're talking and we're round
and so probably in all likelihood she
wants to kind of get up and move and
carry on but she knows she has to be
waiting for Mom
some of her kind of way she looks at
herself and thinks she's almost well
particular this morning and this
afternoon and maybe even a little bit
yesterday evening she's got this almost
like I want to play with you guys but I
don't really know what we're allowed to
do if I'm allowed to come close to you
am I not
she almost has that kind of thought
going through a head at times because
she's got a little kind of playful
demeanor to her and I wonder if she's
quite curious about this car and what
goes on no you know we haven't spent
like I was saying awfully I mean a huge
amount of time on our own with her you
know mom is normally present and in that
case mark the hood the attention is
mostly on her mother but now that she's
kind of spending so much time alone like
this and her brain's founder recently by
herself and I've had one or two
sightings of her on her own but this is
probably the most drives we've strung
together in a row without mom being
present and then she almost seems to be
kind of curious as to what we do in the
way we speak and and how it all works
and so I'm curious to kind of see how
she interacts with us for the rest of
the afternoon as if she's going to just
fall asleep and my dulcet tones or if
she's going to basically wake up and
start to move around
so Kathy viewing of Cubs without needing
their mom they generally until about
eight months so eight months you
wouldn't really view her without mom you
normally try and kind of keep them to
leave them to themselves at eight months
old obviously if you find her you can
have a short sighting and then let them
go but now that she's a year old yeah
she's more than capable of climbing
trees and and figuring out things on her
own and I watched her last night with
the hyenas that approached her as during
our rehearsal she was on top of the
termite mound and I ena came along and
she didn't even bat an eyelid she just
looked at that in a line he looked at
her they both kind of said uh too much
effort to go anywhere and lift one
another alone so she's you know she's
figured things out and in a year old she
needs to because theoretically tandy
could leave her in the next two months
actually did the tambour before and
she's gonna need to figure things out
and obviously when she's on her own we
can view her so it's important that we
also start to spend time with her away
from tandy because otherwise she'll
never get relaxed with the fact that the
vehicles are here and so she's had a
pretty long period to live life by
herself and for us not to stress her out
too much by herself but now you know as
we start to get to a year old she's
gonna be starting to hunt and doing
things and she's more than fine with the
vehicles around we as you can see we're
not exactly stressing her out at this
stage although she is watching Batman
now look at the size of that pore in
relation to a head when she's stretching
you're just doing all the poses today
aren't you it's almost like she's just
listening to what we're saying and kind
of watching what's going on and her
little one you're so serious
you like your brother you know that yes
she's enjoying a conversation about her
royalty and herself it's quite funny
from my angle which you probably won't
have is you'll see that these two leaves
in front of her face from the quarry
tree now that those tubes they're from
the angle that I am at when she puts her
head in a certain way those are the
perfect little moustache over her nose
it's quite funny I'll try and line it up
just now with Craig because it's
hilarious
with these two little green leaves like
hanging down and either side of him as
well looks like she's got say
massive mustache and there was an
Australian cricketer that if some of you
maybe maybe we should google because he
had an epic massage that looks a little
bit like this when her face is aligned
and his name was Mervyn Hughes who was a
bad-boy cricketer and he was you know
all over the place and he had this huge
handlebar moustache and this kind of
looks just like that over a face except
it's a quarry Bush Michelle moustache
should I say and so it's very very cute
when she it's just she needs to get her
head in the right place and
unfortunately where Craig is is not
quite the right sort of you it was so
obviously blocks her face a lot in my
kind of good Craig there but we'll try
it just now to see if we can get their
little quarry moustache on totally
lumber what are you doing right I'm
gonna try and see if I can find some
sort of place to align the leaves on her
muzzle and while I do that let's send
you back across to James Andrews playing
apparently Where's Waldo with the
cheaters of the Maasai Mara triangle oh
my god from that link everybody is that
I'm going to find something to lump a
lead with Columbus moustache I don't
think that's what it was anyway
we are still trying our best to find the
cheater on this gorgeous afternoon not
feeling in the slightest but frustrated
feeling the strattice with pressures
because it's so pretty
oh it was about two llamas moustache I
see that's very odd
I didn't know tree lumber had a
moustache I've found him a starch and a
woman to be particularly attractive
but each to each to his own our leaf
mustachio run and that's okay then now I
think I'm told that she has a den
somewhere in between these two hills
which I think that the things we're
heading towards now but if it is a bit
of broken telephone that you get out
here and apparently she was lying
without the Cubs earlier today which
means she could easily have left them at
least lift where she was to go and feed
them so we'll just pop around here there
are elephants about so if we see
something we will show them to just
being in a landscape like this is
there's magic and smell so clean there
hardly any other vehicles are armed and
basically have the place to ourselves
all 50,000 hectares or so some 120,000
acres Zak my favorite thing about the
Mara is the space I mean yeah really if
you look at that that is my favorite
thing about the Mara it's just endless
gorgeous gorgeous views obviously the
animals are spectacular as well and it's
lovely to have so many here but it's the
real sense of space that you get here I
think because you can see so far
you know the Mara Serengeti is no bigger
than the Kruger but obviously in the
Kruger you can't see the same distance
there just gives you a sense of real
space and I guess because it's parkland
in other words because there's short
grass and trees dotting it it makes us
psychologically feel very comfortable
there's a psychological phenomenon in
human beings where we seek out parkland
with few tall trees but a pretty short
grass underneath that's why we design
our parks like that and it comes from
way back when when we would just learn
to stand because it means we can see for
a distance but we still have the
security of the trees quite interesting
I think all right let's keep going
no luck is yet
we will go back to those cheetahs at
least to the Lions if we do not come
right with these cheetahs
you know what else we didn't use to have
signal in this area when I was last here
and that was all rectified during our
gauntlet series it was very special to
be able to drive in this area and share
it with you
party Sydney is looking for some leon's
so I think we're gonna find out how that
search is going so I am now busy trying
to get hold of the freshly on tracks it
seems like these liens are much more
towards the Geary cut line somewhere
there is where maybe we might be lucky
and find them I'll just go check that
area as well as the buffers walk them as
the buffers of them is the nearest gem
to where these liens has been spotted
earlier this morning the wind is too
much here where I am
so there's no other animals here in this
area maybe this is a sign that the big
cats are somewhere around here so I'm
gonna have to look very carefully
because these kind of animals can lie
down flat and it's not easy to see the
Lions when they are lying down during
this time of the day unless you know
where exactly they are still no tracks
at the moment as soon as I pick up some
tracks I will be able to tell where how
much time we are going to take to find
him
so now let's go to Tristan well mr. with
the total number you can see she's now
found a nice little spot to rest here
poor is that comfy go do you like that
little spot yes okay you will come to
like whatever spot you want which you
can see there that Cory's made the
perfect little spot to kind of hang
one's paw over and imagine it's much
like leaning against a shelf or
something like that that's what's it
really kind of I would think it would be
Oh leaning against a sort of bar counter
or something maybe she's a little bit
young for the bar counter maybe you need
to perfect your skill for later in life
she's getting to that age where she's
going to be going out on the town at
nights and then going and checking
around things on her own what you
noticing the wind is really blowing at
the moment and so I'm pretty sure
there's a lot of noise and a lot of
sounds and lots of kind of things that
are disrupting hers from trees rustling
to grass moving and there's a few birds
that are chirping and so I'm sure she's
just kind of watching art from all of
that Connie I would imagine maybe you in
the initial phases they would probably I
suppose when they really stung they
don't even know what's going on and so
being left alone probably doesn't mean
anything to them really and then they
just get used to it
but I would imagine if things like lions
come past where they get chased up a
tree or something like that and I'm sure
they go through a period of anxiety or
at least an emotional stress but for the
most part I don't think so I think it's
more boredom than anything else when
they sitting like this and you can
imagine she's been sitting here for
since yesterday morning waiting for mom
to return me like come on let's go some
whales and she's just had to kind of sit
siddhart and wait now what will happen
eventually in time is that she will
start to move around a lot more social
start hunting she'll start going and
looking for water and eventually the the
periods of time is just going to
increase in more and more and more and
the sort of a creation from tandy is
going to be that much more
that she's going to have to be left kind
of on her own and figure things out but
I think it's a little bit early she's so
little I would be a bit too nervous of
her being on her own at this age already
and being left to do her in things I
think it would be a very tricky period
for her if she were to be left by
herself at this time I mean she's still
very little in comparison to you know
some of the comparison to you know a lot
of the other depends on Jim to compete
with that Scottish female up near
Buffalo Tandy which other you know
should you do it it would be very tricky
for her and Annie Annie to be and in
Canyon his daughter - he's gonna come of
age and you know she's gonna have a
tough time of it - you stay out of
trouble and stay away from anybody
that's going to try and hurt you so I'm
hoping that Tandy is kind and keeps her
for a little while longer maybe sort of
I would hope six more months that should
get her to a nice sort of size that
she'll be able to then look after
herself a lot better because I remember
with Jean he knows the exact same chunky
there was tiny tiny tiny tiny and around
a year old she looked as though she was
half the size of husana and in the space
of about six months she really grew
quite a bit as soon as she started
making her own kills and I'm developing
you know she started to really kind of
come in to learn and develop in size
ultimately she was still quite small and
obviously Tandy sort of chased her away
and we know that there's that whole
interaction but I would be very very
very kind of hesitant for it to go now
and I'm hoping that she'll show similar
pattern to show Neely and actually
starts to really kind of move and to try
and kind of actually what would you call
it grow and be able to then hunt so Lady
Bird her eyes are quite interesting
they've changed color slightly they I
mean when we first started to see her
they were weren't actually the brightest
of colors and they didn't really look
like they were going to be anything
spectacular but in the last few months
they've almost starting to take on a
little bit more of a kind of greenish
color if you look at them there is a
sort of slight under
it's not much it's mostly sort of yellow
based hood but it was definitely a bit
more of a lightness in that I mean she's
starting to really kind of get these
beautiful eyes that's that the time
these kind of Cubs are known for she
said boys had Cubs that have had pretty
eyes and so you know she's almost taking
one that lights kind of yellow almost
translucent yellow with touch of greeny
blue in them which is very very pretty
so she's got a really nice kind of set
of eyes I'm I like the eyes that she's
got obviously Tamas eyes with
extraordinary and then beautiful in his
own right but hers are really taking on
a nice color now and it's often what
happens with lipids as as Cubs their
eyes are a certain color and in there
slowly but surely start to change a
little bit as they gets a little older
and you'll find that they in depending
on which leopard it is and eyes get a
little bit more subdued in terms of the
vividness of the color if you take
tianni for example she had sapphire blue
eyes and when I say sapphire blue I mean
they were blue blue blue blue blue blue
and those faded somewhat and have now
become more like Anderson's eyes which
is this kind of grey grey blue but very
very light and that's not the same
sapphire blue that we've been seeing on
when she was a cub and so you see that
with the Cubs they the are kind of
changes and it gets a little more muted
as they go but whose is definitely
getting more of a green tone to it and
as she's getting older which is quite
nice but I think she's got beautiful
eyes it was a very serious face that
look at that I know you did one
delightful so just so you everybody
knows it's apparently Jamie Patterson is
is apparently a TV star now she's you
know gone to the Mara done TV become
famous for her work with hyenas and as
its decided that she doesn't actually
want to participate in the afternoon
show anymore she'll do TV this evening
but the rest of the time she's going to
gain spend her time back at camp at
their feet up being pampered and being
brought all kinds of things by the
trainees so she's apparently this is
through the grapevine she's ordered
caviar and champagne in order to sit
back and relax while she gets a facial
it's just what the grapevine is saying
and I think it's probably because she
hits all-time fame actually this morning
with her poetry she's well from what I
hear is being coined as the next
Shakespeare the Shakespeare of the
modern era and so she's not you know it
was just too much work this morning for
her to do another game Drive this
afternoon and say she's decided to go
put her feet up until such time as TV
comes around but she can then be the
star of the show once again so for now
she's going to just take it easy back at
camp
apparently saying that I shouldn't be
jealous as she's putting on her charcoal
facemask okay so yeah I'm not jealous at
all I'm sitting with a leopard which is
probably for me the best place to be we
all know that as long as I'm out and is
a spotty cat around I'm quite happy with
where I am so I don't mind at all
but I mean Jamie I hope you enjoy your
pamper session and you're you're relaxed
afternoon I'm glad that you're getting
some time off you know though you
wouldn't want to work you too hard over
the course of the next few days you
obviously know that you are a vitally
important as the star of the show and so
we will pamper when we need to now what
I'm gonna try to do is well little
Emma's got her face up did Jamie say a
naughty word to me that's naughty Kirsty
I'm gonna try and line up Craig Craig
can I ask you just to keep I know it's
gonna be a bit rough but I just want to
see her face with the little moustache
let's see if we can get this right okay
little Columbo you've got to keep your
face where it is I know there's gonna be
a stick in the way to line it up perfect
if I get it right I can also come home
Craig let's see going tighter there
let's have a look
oh no her face is not quite right it was
almost there if she just drops her face
come on put your face back little amber
there little moustache is the perfect
thing let's see if she'll do it I think
she will do it eventually again but at
one point she had the perfect height on
her face that it was just sitting
directly over her nose but there you can
see if she drops her head down a little
bit
can you imagine that over it will be
hilarious if we can get this right come
on to the lumber which will nose down a
little bit so we can see with a little
gory moustache
case he says this is we need a laser
beam because cats always chase lasers
around and say they can just make her
kind of put a muzzle down although I
don't think a laser beam would work
Kirsty I think she'll be too reacted for
that so what we want is for word to get
for her to get a little sleepy and just
to drop her face slightly and look kind
of down a bit I know she's she is very
close I agree cursed it almost seems
like she's going to get it right the
problem is is this squirrels alarm
calling someone if mom's on her way back
to our south is some squirrels there you
go look at that we can say she's got a
quarry beard now and it may not be a
massage but she's got she's got a little
worried beard at the moment and I'm
sorry go with making fun of you on to me
but it's willing to just everyone's
enjoying it there's a little it's
ridiculous she looks like a catfish so
say like yes it looks like one of those
those old and a Chinese mustaches or
there's you know there's ones that are
long and hanging down it's it really is
quite wonderful I like it I think it's
fantastic don't look so angry with me
I'm sorry go I guess I knew you would
did enjoy that I thought it was quite
cool to actually see I'm glad that all
worked out because obviously with the
camera angle and my angle is two
different things so sometimes when we
see something the camera doesn't quite
get it because it's a lot steeper of an
angle than what I have and so you end up
with these kind of different sort of
looking things but luckily Julie exactly
it is Movember Columba is doing her butt
for Movember there it is it's it is
ridiculous now just mute there we go
that's it it's perfect when it comes out
of here knows it's the things that keep
us entertained at this time of the day
this is what happens when we spend time
out in the hot Sun is there
three gal brains gets stood anywhere
we're gonna sit and enjoy this a little
bit longer while Jamie Patterson takes
it easy up in camp but the other one
who's not having as much fun as what we
are or Jamie is James Henry as he's
still playing his game of where is the
spotted cat upon the plains of East
Africa it must be nice to be a TV star I
think I think must be great to be just a
TV star that Thompson's gazelle is not
TV starts now minor until it's Liberty
anyway we're sitting here we have yet to
find our cheetah but what we have found
or two glorious are abhi look at those
are they're not magnificent we are still
searching for these cheetahs but as I
keep saying to you this way of by way of
consolation we're looking for lots of
other things and seeing beautiful
landscapes or Obie's thompson's ghazals
general beauty Jaime Patterson has
herself a cup of coffee isn't that
gorgeous
those are not common in fact that's the
best or be sighting I've ever had would
be just slightly better if there was a
cheetah chasing them magic
here's Kirsten er would be sad as they
died but we just want the cheetah
running after them we don't necessarily
want to see them torn limb from limb do
we know it would be disgusting all right
we're going to continue along here going
towards to very large fig trees and then
we're gonna bend our way around and if
we don't have any luck we'll go back to
the Lions we don't want to lose them
it's not very warm anymore I mean it's
warm that it's not hot
no Debbie I don't know anything about
the wild dogs from this morning I'm
afraid uh you know where they came from
where they're going I do know that they
went into the villages straightaway so
whether they ate goat for breakfast I'm
not sure it's the one or one of the
disadvantages of not having secure
fences in an area like this you know
they they just bleed onto community land
which in in one respect is wonderful
because the wild animals go into the
communities and they've actually
developed a really pretty good
understanding of each other but on the
other hand while dog goes into
communities and starts killing livestock
it's a problem and so I don't know where
they came from who they are but it was
so exciting to see them as you may have
noticed if you were watching this
morning Paulie got fairly excited by the
fact that he was seeing wild dogs in the
Maasai Mara for the first hunt he's
sitting behind me his teeth are showing
it's very special indeed so we're going
to cut down through this little valley
once we get to the two big fig trees see
if we get lucky
we may we may not
we'll do a little scan from the top here
Oh Rach hey Cathy we're very close to
the equator we're almost on the equator
here we're just a little bit south the
equator is I don't know how far north it
is mana do you know let's have a scan
through here I'm not sure how far away
the Equator is but it's really not far
at all you do cross it in Kenya if you
go north and so really very pleasant
climate here especially because we're so
high up you've got some pigs em on you
well done
pigs water pigs there's a huge sound of
water pigs that don't look very panicked
my life of course a cheetah would think
twice about taking on a Waterpik the
water pigs don't always know that you've
seen any time I see a Thompson's gazelle
herring around the place I assume that's
being chased sometimes I just hair
around now I see may cheetah I suspect
those are not the only two fig trees
next to each other in the whole place
the reason I say that is that there
we've been told to look for them while
looking for the cheeto girl just just
gorgeous we should have a fairly
gorgeous sunset as well I'm sure you can
feel the peace of this place just by
looking at your screen and these are
magnificent visitors just utterly
utterly breathtaking well Joshua the
migration never ends completely the
migration continues regardless just
doesn't happen to be right here where we
are most of the animals have gone down
south into Tanzania but actually just
over the ridge to the north east of us
there is a place called a soft Lick
which many of you will be familiar with
and in fact there are huge herds of
zebra and wildebeest all around the Salt
Lick and we passed a few herds of
wildebeest sansa but today on our way
down here but basically over that Ridge
there that you're looking at here's the
Salt Lick and they will find fairly
substantial hurts - all certainly three
days ago you did whether they're still
there I'm not sure but most likely
really is the kind of place you need to
sit and just soak it all up
doc drinking Dean ready
yes you can hear bird Thank You Kirsten
the bird you can hear is the waffled
left wing not a peaceful Sunday
afternoon sound but that is the salad
has chosen to make alright I think we
better carry on that's an elephant skull
there sewn elephant popped its clogs as
it were some time ago over there righty
good shall we carry on driving let's
carry on driving
so the two fig trees little road going
down this way yes here we go be lucky
okay let's go back to the other color of
the moment it's not so much a cub
anymore well no exactly you're not so
much a cop anymore
at all she's gotten quite big these days
and I suppose she still is you know a
bit of a cubby face is she's trying very
hard to have a stone stair and get rid
of the cubby face and I suppose that's
making fun of a halving of lament you
massage really doesn't help in this case
at all but like I said we weren't having
fun we were laughing with her it's what
you always got to remind yourself but
she's now decided sleep time enough
entertaining with mustaches and the
likes she's going to slide on and have a
little bit of an happen I suppose this
is what happens when we spend time
Archer for long periods and and not much
goes on is that we start to come up with
ridiculous things that lipids get to do
and obviously entertain ourselves
someone so I can only imagine what it
must be like for her it was such a
non-stop all day long waiting for mum to
come out
I am surprised though that you know
obviously this morning we saw a hunt
with a lot of vigor and energy and all
seriousness try go after some impalas it
wasn't like she was kind of taking it
easy and just doing a little playful and
she was really hunting properly and it
surprises me that's since then she's
just not done anything because there's
still lots of impalas around this area
seen quite a few different impalas kind
of moving about there on both sides of
the drainage line we are we sitting at
the moment so there's a drainage line
just to our kind of what would we say
North I would imagine a Craig Northwest
somewhere there and there's parlors that
are kind of on both sides of that so
there's someone this on the far side
they way that termite mound is in the
background and that was where I last saw
some of them and in there some just to
us could it's kind of south and so I'm
surprised that off to that hunt this
morning she hasn't tried again to go
after anything maybe she's just kind of
decided that's it's too bright now and
that she's gonna rather wait for Mom
maybe she thought mom would be back a
lot earlier than what she has now I'm
hoping
tonight's Tandy does come back at some
point so one of the niconico viewers
know we haven't searched for Tandy too
much I did drive so basically what
happened is yesterday this interaction
happened with hyenas the kill was stolen
in the morning and Tandy went south so
turn you in towards cheetah Plains in
coral Chad red boundary and from there
no one's seen her so I've driven the
fire break which runs to the south of
the block that we're in no sign of any
tracks coming back north and obviously
we can't reverse in coral cheetah Plains
and so you know ask the guys they said
they haven't seen any side of it it's
not to say she isn't there she can be
elusive in the places where she's
crossed on Saturdays and night me for
finding a leopard it's very very dense
bush there so she could just be in a
some weight and it wouldn't surprise me
and so what the best bait fast is is
obviously we could drive around and try
and find her but if she's got a kill
she's going to come back to Kalama at
some point and come and fetch her and
take her back or at some point she's got
to arrive back here so the bait sisters
rather just sit tight with Columba and
wait for mom to arrive and the other
thing is is that I just wanted to spend
more time with if I'm really honest I'm
being selfish a little bit hopefully you
guys don't mind a bit ID we get so
little time with Tandy and Kalama
because of their way that they spending
time on tortured and we also know that
difficult cut to find is Tandy at the
best of times and so when you got an
opportunity to spend three drives in a
row with little Claire Lambert
it just feels like a really nice thing
to do and then eventually mom's gonna
come back and getting that moment of
them rejoining and coming back together
is very special and on top of that if we
can follow them back to a kill if she
does have a kill that means that we then
have terve then for a longer period even
further and we have a better place to
start if I leave Claire laminar and
let's say Tandy comes from this western
side where there's no Road up this
drainage line and then takes her back I
won't have any idea where she's gone and
it'll be very difficult for me to be
able to or any of us to be able to find
her again and that means that we won't
be on kind of on top of what's going on
with him and that's the problem with
onion Columbia they're actually not too
bad if you follow them every Drive and
you try
keep looking for them it's when you lose
them for a drive than you've done then
they generally are gone and move all
over the place and it becomes quite
tricky to find them once again so you
know I think it's best plan for now is
just to sit with her and hope that mom
comes back and that we can follow where
they go I'm hoping that sandy wavers she
is did not kill on in coral because
obviously that means that she's going to
come here grab a little one and back
onto in Coral in a space of about 10
minutes and there won't be really much
that we can do about it and also we
don't want them to go outside that's not
to decide that we can drive we want our
little ones to be this side and to stay
you know area I doubt that she'll go too
far south with quarantine being around
and also um you know that skittish male
its seeming he is spending time around
Chitra I doubt that we getting to see
too much movement I've turned II to the
south she might go and explore on her
own but I don't know if she'll take
little Colombo that side just yet right
now while we kind of spend time with
Colombia and see what she gets up to
let's send you back across to Sydney who
still on the trail of the tawny cats
I just got the tracks of the Lions here
where I am not too sure where exactly
these tracks are heading to so I'm
trying to check here because it seems
like we got disappeared somewhere here
so I am from the buffer swoop damn this
lands has been there for drinking
purposes earlier on
so I just have to check all these small
bushes here because this kind of
predators can easily lie down and it's
difficult to see them from a long
distance
so maybe the Trix are heading back to
the main road because I can see I'm not
very far away from the main road at the
moment and this tracks looks like it's
for the males so it maybe is a
correlation so there's even more tracks
here showing going up this side things
has been happening here so I'm just
gonna show you the tracks here so that
you can see this lounge has been here on
the ground I can see it's nice and clear
they you can see those are the fresh
tracks of these lions so the chances of
seeing the Lions in the area they are
getting very high at the moment it's
just that the wind is blowing which is
making it very difficult for me to judge
the age of these tracks so I'm just
going to pull forward and see if maybe
we can check around here until we pick
up convincing evidence so now let's go
to a gem so it's looking for the
Cheetahs at the moment
I'm afraid we've kind of given up on our
cheater simply because we don't want to
miss the Lions waking up from the Cubs
and end up with a TV show wafting a
spotlight around there's nothing to see
never be hopeless there's a beautiful
zebra
you can look at that just look at the
beautiful zebra good evening madam
yes I see that you are pregnant heavily
well done good job
he only carried your baby to term some
11 months she's had to have that thing
in her belly Kirsten we're not going
down the road of silly puns this evening
there were enough of those yesterday
evening for the Lightning there's the
Sun going down
I wanted that Sun going down either
behind the cheetah awesome lions so
we're going to press on
are you ready money yeah
little Rufe nape locking call it after
me James yes
not sure she will
it might be very fortunate as we sort of
drive through here and bump into her I
think she's probably spent the day away
from her cubs because I've got an idea
where the Cubs in China was so we might
catch her coming back this way
hello zebras the other thing I love
about the Mari you're asking me what I
love about it the most is the smell it's
just a lovely smell lovely fresh verdant
grass no Mary we are allowed to get out
of the car if we wish to relieve
ourselves but we cannot get out and go
tracking or walking no that is not
allowed here it's because it's a
national reserve basically and you can
get MIT people on you know the public
can drive in suck the Kruger Park in
South Africa you can you can go walking
with a with a ranger who works for the
place and we've done that once or twice
but you can't just get out of the car
and walk because obviously people will
be flattened by the various fauna that
have human flattening properties buffalo
in elephant come to mind in parts of
botswana and zimbabwe you can do what
you like and there well it's I'm not
surprising that they do lose people
every year they put up a sign that says
you know go walking at your own risk and
well people do and sometimes the risk
doesn't pay off
now I think that during the gauntlet
series when Scott and Brent were
knocking around down here
the grass was probably about four feet
tall and it's now been eaten flat by the
migration as it came - yes Paula there
are no marilla trees here in the Maasai
Mara no you find them I think a little
bit further south in Tanzania you do not
find them here though so they don't have
a great marula Jam via general festivity
season yes they do in the low felt which
I've explained to you results in well an
enormous lack of productivity human
beings become vegetables for a little
while if the marula season is in play
now that's not a cheat here either
mind back to the Lions we go alright
sustain remains with Columba and the
moustache you go back there well no she
doesn't have been a starch anymore she's
now traded that in for a nest she's
decided she's going to go lie back where
the grassy part is she's had enough of
being ridiculed with no what are you
plants in her face and is now going to
lie looking very very regal in amongst
the grass over there so she looks quite
content doesn't she she seems oh she's
going to have a bit of a nap I think the
other vehicle arriving just now was yeah
probably a little bit kind of didn't
feel like it's and so she moved off a
little bit and has decided this is
exactly where she can kind of see and
watch what's going on you feel
comfortable with this sort of grass
behind her back
Aidan who's seven years old well Hayden
we have a magic wand and basically what
happens is the magic wand is given to
one of the trackers or the ranges that
work out here and it goes in the company
of that animal and they wave the magic
wand and a name spews forth and comes
out of the end and that's how we know
what they are now I'm shaking it and
that's not the case at all basically how
it works is that we will watch a leopard
or a lion or coalition lions are a
little bit different to lipids in many
respects line coalitions normally have a
name or prides have a name from an area
that they've inhabited or something that
makes them kind of get that name and
most of the prides of their names for
quite some time that it's very sort of
seldom that a new name comes along but
essentially what happens is that the
Rangers that work in the areas whereas
the trackers they all get together and
they will put forward names that are
traits that this this animal shows so
let's say like with Kleber meaning
mischievous or playful or
kind of they will then they decide okay
well that's how she is and so let's give
that name and
with her we got three names and you you
all decided which name you wanted to use
but he was engineer that's how it works
I mean some areas it's not quite that
they'll pick our three names I'll just
pick out one but it is the guides that
work on sites and normally it's the
first guide that gets to see them would
say the lumber was farmed by taxon
first taxon will be normally the one
that gets per first preference as to
what name he would like to put forward
for that lipid and ID kind of name for
her so that's how it works us as guides
for for wild earth we don't really
participated in it at all so even though
we were the first ones to see little
clamber we didn't put forward any names
at all we asked Herbie to kind of
represent us in that regard and Herbie
kind of put the name forward with the
rest of the guides and that's how we got
all the names for her to choose from so
you know that's happened when he works
it's sort of out of a little bit of
respect you know Herbie in tax and
Aubrey and William and Finnerty they've
spent so much time out in this area and
Rickson and they they do a lot of
tracking on footage and they find a lot
of animals for us and they help us so
much that you know they've been here for
much longer and the the naming of these
animals is far more kind of you know
they they have the language they know
the language they know the animals well
and so it just feels better for for them
to be doing it then first you know we
kind of come in and art and and none of
us as guides have been here for remotely
as long as what they have and so I don't
know it feels better that they kind of
do it then what we do and then it's also
then removes any kind of emotion amongst
presenters or anything like that or any
boastfulness
we're happy with however it goes as long
as you know it's the right kind of name
that the guys have offered forward from
themselves and not just kind of mean
push it into it by us and the fact that
they allow us to kind of participate in
it is always very nice so it's a kind of
return respect that they have in many in
many ways and that we can also include
all of you is them being very kind of
what would the would be well they
acknowledge the fact that it's very
important that's you know we have these
kind of ID kits and that all of you like
to be able to associate a name with with
an animal and then allow all of you to
participate
in what an amazing kind of environment
we're in as well as the specialness of
making a connection with suits and
animals so yeah I think works all the
way around hopefully that wasn't too
long and answer but it is the way that
it goes is basically the guides that the
payment that are from that particular
Lodge where that lipid is basically born
or whatever the cat is that's born in
and like I say you know things like
cheetah and lions don't really get
individual names unless this is a a real
kind of trait that they have here in
South Africa and the Masai Mara is
slightly different there you'll find all
the male lions pretty much have names a
lot of even the females do too and all
the cheetah because of how many they are
have names as opposed to the lipids
they're mostly lipids have no idea at
all so it's quite interesting hard down
here because we see a lot more liquid in
this cheetah all our lipids really have
ID kits where's the cheetah a little bit
kind of unknown whereas you know it's
the complete opposite and you've done
well you're still going to sit and wait
for Mom I was hoping she was gonna go up
towards the termite mound and pose
beautifully for us in the late afternoon
lights but I don't think we're going to
get that something that's going to be a
push to filing she's going to decide to
have a bit more of a nap and take it
very very easy and wait for Mom to start
coming back rather than kind of moving
around too much I really do hope sandy
comes back this evening it will be so
nice if she doesn't it'll definitely I
don't make things quite interesting
because I'm quite keen to see where she
goes and which way she comes from I was
excited I don't know I mean I suppose
it's possible you never know with Sandy
she does some random things at random
times and especially could be coming
into an Easter cycle again and she made
it only when she mated with
with Tigana to to basically have a
number so it's possible that she could
be going to nice recycle but you know
the thing about Tandy is that I would be
very very very surprised as that if she
went into a nice recycle and didn't hook
up with ting Ghana its most of her
territory falls within his and it would
surprise me if we didn't find her also
she's such a relax cats and when she's
mating it's actually much easier to find
it than it isn't because of her
frequency of mating and so we would have
heard the reports of her mating
somewhere I don't think she can creep
around here without anybody finding her
and so I don't think she's in the
associates but it will come soon it's
gonna be within the next I would say
three months we're gonna start to see
her coming to first Easter cycles and
obviously when that happens and she
mates then that kind of a break of her
and Columbus starts to really kind of
happen particularly if she starts to
feel like these little ones inside her
then she starts to get quite aggressive
quite quickly towards Solomon it'll be
very kind of interesting to see where
the number ends up will she spend more
time on the side and tortured will she
go back to kind of where she was born in
that area I suspect she's going to hang
around between sort of I reckon around
Torchwood camp and then afterwards
before like damn that kind of swathe
there's going to be where Clara is going
to spend a bit of time the only problem
is is that that skittish females being
seen around Bethel's exam a few times
now and so maybe a little bit further
south might be better for her but it'll
be interesting because obviously
traditionally Tandy's always would favor
the eastern side of Juma and the western
side of torture Edwards within can yeni
having her side and her little female
who's gonna end up settling where he's
going to be quite kind of interesting
good we're gonna sit with this little
cat tree and see when it gets up to the
meantime they're back to Sydney who's so
searching for the Lions
I was not lucky with lions the minute I
got somewhere near the buffers woke the
Lions crossed right into the buffers
book area so now I am changing the plans
going down to the cheetah cheetah them
in order to see what is happening around
the chitra area so the two male lions
has just crossed maybe they will come
back afterwards shortly after the sunset
I'll come back again and see if there
will be some lion activities later on so
this fire break here next to me is
starting to recover the moment you see
there's an area where there was a
control band dance some few months ago
but now I can see that his is now
starting to get green again so soon as
we receive good rains this fabric is
going to be completely green
anomalous even starting to feed you can
see some impalas now are excited to feed
from the fire break so these are the
impalas were going to pressurize this
fire break because feeding here too much
is going to take home a lot of nutrients
and the grasses is not going to bring
more nutrients until the rain is back
so the Impala said they might start
giving birth from the second week of
December a second week of November
normally which will be in two weeks have
not December which will be any weeks
enough time that is when they are
starting to give bad so hopefully we
might start to see the little ones then
the Lambs anytime soon so when giving
birth impalas are too clever they most
of them they I have been lucky with an
Impala giving birth before and impalas
normally they give birth during the
daytime when they know that the
predators is when they're inactive so at
night they know it's very dangerous
most of their babies they are coming
during the day
so I'm just about to get to the chitra
cheated em at the moment maybe you might
be lucky with some other lions day the
humans they like that area a lot let's
hope for the best
maybe we'll be lucky also with one of
the spotted cats so what I like the most
about schita Chitra is that I always hit
two birds with one stone
so the traditional area is full of
surprises so now let's go back to the
Maasai Mara
where James is also driving around in
search of the lovely animals but we're
back trying to find the Lions we haven't
quite arrived where we left them nearly
such a flutter in the stomach as to
whether or not they're going to be there
nearly there
Sun is going down Lions could start to
move just about here wasn't it was it
further along Manu further along my the
next tops of trees
hello Schuyler ah when to be to do this
job you've got to be very old like me
I'm 27 and you need to be about 27 to do
this job no I'm not 27 I'm not going to
tell you all I am but you need to be in
South Africa you need to have was here
you need to have a driver's license
which means you need to be at least 18
I'm in a mild panic now just gonna look
inside this little drainage line
hopefully they're there with the Cubs
there's a lion Oh small panic don't
worry so surely you need to be at least
18 to drive a car you've got to have 21
21 to guide so it's actually guide
people you've got to be 21 years old but
to do this job to present to drive a car
and talk to camera I guess all you
really need is a driver's license and a
well a pretty good knowledge of the
wilderness so as long as you have those
two things any a journey thanks goodness
Sparrow the Sassari pride where are
their babies that's what I want to know
they're on the move so they could be on
the hunt we arrived just at the right
time not have been fun who have arrived
here a little bit later
now will we see some baby sausages have
to be I can be the best you want you on
this angle I knew once this angle of the
sausage tree pride there we go
I'll sit still now shot I'm on him I
know likes me just sit still
not breakdance on the back here Kirstin
sarcastic manner very artistic it's not
the kinky don't know it's not kinky tell
King he tells one of the other two we
have here no Cubs as yet and only two
lionesses there are five in the society
tree pride and you can tell that the one
is kinky tail and by the colour of her
nose which is in fact purple I'm being
sarcastic you can tell by the kink in
her left foot yes keep watching keep
watching no that's not her
wonderful it's what he told Kirsten what
did she say
cuz it's straight tail flippy tail so
funny got a gorgeous sunset going on I'm
gonna move forward and then we will get
you a picture of the sunset Kirsten I
think you should be quiet
you reached a pinnacle of your joke
skills that's kinky tail there your joke
skills reach their Apogee yesterday
evening with the lightning
that is a heavily heavily pregnant
darkness well hopefully they'll lead us
to the Cubs but let's just go a little
bit forward and show you this gorgeous
sunset which is going down behind kinky
tail Jerrod the era for so the era for
that really is rather lovely
I'm afraid that camera can really do
justice to the actual site we are seeing
here recently I'm not sure that they
have I think that no this one
flippy tail that's kinky tell there she
doesn't look very fat but she looks
foolish is that kinky no she yes it is
she got a kink in hotel I don't even see
she did his hair yes I've definitely
been eating something but I think that
other one was also very heavily pregnant
and all of you enjoying the sunset
thank you yes we're enjoying it - very
gouges I was trying to take some illegal
pictures of us and just just not vaguely
doing it justice so we're the other two
members of the society pride art I don't
know but I'm going to hang around with
these three it goes well I think that's
a pretty good return I'm not going to
take in a legal picture with my
telephone
yes
good
- pretty
now they've got up moved from where they
were and I wonder if they've left the
Cubs because they're gonna go hunting or
if perhaps it's the other two that have
comes ah there's a thought that maybe
they're going to go in search of the
other tooth this all next to us is
either very pregnant all very full of
food but see how she's not breathing
very heavily
lady Starfire that's an interesting
question and I mean it's it's obviously
there's a complicated answer to it you
say if I came across a lion giving birth
would I stay in the psyching the answer
is it depends entirely on the effect
that I was having on the sighting if we
drove up onto this riverbed here look
down and there was a lioness giving
birth in a cat in a cave and she didn't
move because she's had matured into
vehicles like these ones are
then I would sit very quietly and watch
absolutely would I tell anyone about it
probably not because you know in a lodge
situation you absolutely wouldn't stay
because if one set of guests thought
that guy you know every other guide
would want to show their guest the same
thing then every other guest would want
to see the same thing which means that
inevitably you would have to put
pressure on that cat and it would be a
disaster for the cat but if you happened
to stumble across a lioness giving birth
and she didn't react to you at all well
there's no reason not to stay with her
unless you are convinced that you are
going to in some way endanger the lives
of the Cubs or the lioness and well I
just don't think that that's always the
case and it's very much similar with
leopard cubs and when we stay with
leopard cubs and I know that you were
asking Tristan earlier whether or not
you know at what stage we stay with Cubs
without their mothers there's no hard
and fast answer for that in a large
situation you have to have a rule
because well human beings being what
they are people are going to push
boundaries to get their guests the best
views guests are going to put pressure
on their guides to get them best views
and so there are boundaries if for
example you're a film crew and you
happen upon a leopard cub on its own
without its mother there there's no
you're not lighting the place up you
know there are a lot of people who are
expert enough to decide whether or not
you can impact that Cubs life if its
habituated and it doesn't happen to be
sort of you know it's in the daytime
you're not gonna be turning on lights
and making a noise well I don't think
you are doing any harm but in a large
environment you have to have these
and what applies to one must apply to
everybody you see and so many of the
places where we operate we do operate in
a kind of Lodge environment certainly
ajumma we operate in a lodge environment
here not so much yeah it's much bigger
obviously but it's why we have a muscari
on the back of the car to give us
guidance if he feels we're putting too
much pressure on the animals Oh Lily I
believe you've given me a thumbs up for
that explanation thank you
really pretty I wonder if they'll go
hunting on heymy Deutz I think there may
well be flat cat as it were the next few
hours but they have moved a bit so maybe
they'll get up and go James you're
wondering if I've ever come across an
abandoned cub a and B if I then took it
in - and I quote protective custody no
now I have never come across an
abandoned cub
nor have I taken an animal into
protective custody as you put it it
would be very tempting to do that but I
wouldn't there are far too many examples
of Cubs being raised in captivity and
then being released into the wild and
being destroyed almost immediately by
the locals by the locals I mean by the
local animals so for example if you were
to bring a lion you found a lion cub and
you thought of shame shame ease its
going to die and you fit it to the
bottle and then you fed it and small
pieces of braavos or sausage until it
was a little bigger and then when it was
about two years old you thought it's big
enough now and frankly I can't afford
the feeding anymore you spoke to experts
and you released it into an area like
this well you can imagine a lot of you
know a lot about animal blue lion
behavior if a two-year-old nomads with
no in experience of the wilderness like
this was to come across a pride of lions
who knows what would happen most likely
there'd kill him and you know you just
wouldn't know how to react and the same
goes for leopards you know if you put a
leopard into an area where leopards can
live you can be very sure that there
will be leopards in that area if they
can live there they will they will be
there and there will be territorial
nobody intolerant of strangers and
especially strangers with no experience
of how to deal with the complexities of
liquid social life pretty sure that
they'll die and there are countless
examples of that Cantus examples
especially you know will to do
filmmakers especially what I love to
document the lives of animals being
raised from Kabul where they've been
rescued and almost universally they they
don't show you the tragic end for those
animals suffer through no fault of the
filmmaker it must be said but it is just
extremely difficult to habituate an
animal to the wild ones that have been
raised in captivity so to make a long
story short I wouldn't as tempting as it
would be to take hold of an abandoned
leopard cub and try and raise it myself
and rescue it it would just be
irresponsible we as a species just like
to be responsible
crickets are starting to cool no frog in
the river bit surrounds us the smell of
this grass is too magical I remember
when I was a student many many years ago
before I go and launch into the street
eyes okay mice
I remember going out for my very first
grassland science grassland Science
Board practical I suppose it was and I
remember the smell and I remember
thinking I've picked the right thing to
study here even if I don't enjoy the
actual subject I love the smell of
coming out on field work alright
somebody who probably doesn't smell so
fly
here's Columbo we're gonna go live now
chat see guys in shortly no we're just
saying it to some of the guys that have
joined us in the site in which you can
see not much has gone on with little
Columbus she's still very very sleepy
she's gonna probably in all likelihood
be like this until such time as night
kicks in and in saying that there last
night we spend most of the evening with
her until about quarter to eight and she
didn't really move too much she sort of
sat around and just kind of sat on top
of a termite mound I wouldn't be
surprised though as night falls that she
moves off the ground and starts to find
a termite mound it's much safer for up
there and she can see a lot more of what
goes on remember that on the ground her
scent is going to be much easier to find
and things like hyenas will be generally
milling about and bhai is obviously have
a nose for things and if they pick up
the scent of leopard they generally come
and scratch around so far safer for her
to to kind of get off the ground and get
on to him and it's much better up there
so I wouldn't be surprised if she gets
up from here and slowly starts to move
her way back towards a whole bunch of
termite mounds where she came from this
morning so she obviously crossed the
road hunting those impalas this morning
and I wouldn't be surprised she hits
back that way and goes and lies upon
them and waits for mom to come back I
really do hope that tiny does come back
there's been lots of squirrels along
hauling kind of around us but so far
nothing has really materialized from its
she certainly doesn't make as though
she's aware of anything around her and
I'm pretty sure as soon as tiny comes
into any sort of this
anyway bill uncle squirrels she'll be
quite interested to see what's going on
so she'll be a good indicator and
probably pretty sure she'll notice
Tandy's arrival before we will and it'll
be interesting with the tiny heads this
way or if she hits further to the east
now only you asking about spot pattern
five four on Columba so you can see
there on her right side is the five one
two three four five and then the other
side is four so it's it's a five four
spot pattern that she has five on the
right form the left which is quite a
quite a large number of spots so a lot
of our lipids that we see here generally
are the three threes mostly what you see
is very few that go over that it's
actually quite scary how many lipids
have a three three spot button never had
many more than five I'm trying to think
of any of the lipids that I've seen that
have had more than five spots there was
one lipid that I remember having seven
but I can't remember who it was or if it
was even in the sabi sands might have
been a picture that I saw from somewhere
else I can't remember but most of them
will have you know one two three four
five is kind of generally what you see
on the the sort of muzzles yeah like I
said husana three three taganas got a
quite a quite a high spot count as well
what is quarantine and James Richard I'm
sure you'll be able to tell me what
quarantine spot pattern is I don't know
if and I've only seen quarantine once on
on safari live and actually once in
general so I don't know him very well I
would be able to recognize him straight
away if I saw him just because you look
so much like a mullah and I've seen so
many photos of him but I don't know what
his spot pattern is it's quite
interesting to kind of think about that
um but she's most of them are all kind
of in the lower numbers November I mean
you need to wake up anytime soon you've
got to show that you've got to put on in
sort of 45 minutes time you need to
start being a little bit more awake than
what's going on last but she was in her
acute phase when we first arrived and
was quite sort of active that we can't
complain too much that she's a little
bit sleepy now
yes exactly cuz we'll ask her nasty to
go back and do the moustache for TV
although I don't think she will to be
honest the links that was a little shady
spot for the day and she is now found a
better spot to sit but you see she's
kind of twitching a little bit that's
typical cats when they're sleeping
you'll find that they do twitch quite a
lot their paws and years and often the
back legs sort of kick out a little bit
and so I'm not surprised if she's having
a really good nap if she hasn't been
mainly as kind of awake that's what she
was when we first arrived which
surprises me because it's getting to
that time of the day where it's cooling
down and the Sun is much lower and I
thought she would have been a little bit
more active now than it was during the
hottest part of the day but you know
young leopards who knows what they
actually think and what goes through
their minds but I'm hoping that she will
wake up at some point because at the
moment she's very sleepy so a lot of you
saying five five this is the debate
that's his rage because brains and I had
this debate the other day about it and
Brent is convinced that he's five four
and and I said to him are you sure and
he said yes and he said he's a sort
quite close and that one spot is
amalgamated with the other but it could
be wrong like I said I mean I does
anyone have really good shot so either
side of her face that they can share
with us and we can in the debate then if
we've got really good shots of it it'll
be quite quite simple I know Brent's got
a really nice side profile of her the
other day on either side so maybe those
or somebody else has got spots to be
honest it's funny in this spot that some
thing is an interesting thing because a
lot of a lot of people who work with
outside of of the areas will use spot
patterns effectively an end certainly
when you're looking at photographs what
patterns is your way to go by a long
shot they're generally the most accurate
obviously but being our chair the spot
pattern almost becomes irrelevant at
times unless you a little unsure then
spots can help but for the most part you
know a lot of the lipids that we see
generally you go by look and by what
they sort of the general overall
appearance of them
how I go about it so I'll kind of look
at her son and I know it's him before I
even kind of see his spots and also
remember that spots are a long way away
for us it's not like a zoomed in picture
that you're getting I mean we kind of
have the camera right on them so when we
see them from afar you know you're going
to learn they sort of normal attributes
and the way that they just look from
distance we can't eyes are not good
enough to see this what's straight away
and so you kind of learn to recognize
them without a spot button you just
learn to see their overall appearance in
the way that they look and and that kind
of generally goes of course there are
times when we get it wrong and then
there's a lot of times where we come
beside these things it's part and parcel
of human area and nature and we don't
have the ability to pause and rewind and
to kind of screen grab something when
we're following a liquid through the
bush so sometimes we get it wrong and
it's not I promise you it's not
intentional when we do but for the most
part it's I find it much easier to Ray
you know as a leopard by its general
looks in trying to look for spot
patterns because it's it's almost
impossible to see spots on both sides of
the face of a leopard when you're
following its particularly if it's
mobile it's one thing if it's sitting
like this and it's posing beautifully
but when they move it's it's unlike me
and it's amazing to me that sometimes in
life it's give me anything because you
know when you see tani or it's a note in
Ghana up close they immediately know who
they are it's it's very difficult but
when they a little bit further away and
a little bit of a thicket sometimes your
mind can play tricks on you and you can
be a little unsure and you kind of call
it and you're not really that kind of
convinced by your sort of idea and then
we need a little closer you realize
actually it's it is them but it's it's
one of those things I mean there's
always each to their own I know some
guides will use spot pits and patterns
religiously for me I don't really sell
all the time when people ask me about
patterns or the lipids that we see I
don't really know them very well at all
because it's not the way that we ID them
obviously if it's a newcomer then we'll
try use that but once you get to know
them very well then it starts to become
almost like I say a little bit difficult
to really notice what the spots are from
the distances that we spend time at but
you can hear there's some pearl spotted
eyelets that are starting to call as
well
now sorry Chris if you can just repeat
that to just broke up when you talking
so apparently Kirstie was starting to
choke and that's why I didn't actually
hear half of what you said but soaked at
our spot patterns inherited no not
exactly
and otherwise you'll find lipids that
would be exactly the same but there are
some spots that seems to kind of carry
through a little bit now I know this is
a big call but if somebody's got a full
profile on a profile but a head-on shot
of Columba with with a kind of normal
look about it not with your eyes wide
and they're maybe like that shot now
your noses and I know a lot of you will
probably think that I'm crazy but she
almost has a few spots that roughly line
up to kind of almost match a little bit
of what Carew does Wow was it doesn't
say wow as easily is what crewless did
but there's definitely a little kind of
shape there that's quite similar so I
think that they do inherit certain spots
on them I don't think it's it's always
going I was obviously not the same in
any way and the spots do differ but
there's certain spots that you sometimes
kind of see on a lipid and he thinks
yourself well that could easily have
carried down from mom or from maybe even
grandmother or father or something like
that and so sometimes you do get these
kind of little markings now she's of
course she's going to hide a hidden R so
that we can't actually get that patent
but it's not like I said it's not a full
Wow like caroule ahead but there's a few
little spots there that kind of look and
remind me a little bit of cruelest spot
pattern between her eyes on her forehead
now she's gonna even tuck it down
further
lift your head so I can see okay but now
you have to turn towards us no she's not
going to do that she's going to sleep
that's better I don't know maybe not
looks a little bit like it to me I don't
know there's a little kind of small
spots that she's got they're not quite
the same marking with I don't know I
mean it's a debate is or is this kind of
talk about whether or not they do in
here it's about that as we know they
differently don't here inherit all of
the spots but I wonder if there's maybe
one or two kind of that come through
here in there and there's so many spots
on them that to check every single one
would be quite tricky in terms of
matching them all up and seeing whether
or not spots carry through from the
adults and and also how far back to you
go because maybe it skips a generation
or something like that
I don't know interesting kind of topic I
don't know if anyone's ever studied it
to be honest as to where their spots
carry over from the parents
number is it wake up time are you gonna
still sleep for a while longer seems
like we're gonna sleep for a while
longer
yep I'm going to go back to sleep I
really do hope Tandy arrives at some
point it would be nice to see ton you
two don't see much of her these days and
she's been very elusive as her be kind
of looking forward to her having come
today and very surprised that she hasn't
made an appearance yet at all over the
course of the last 24 hours
Columbus been sitting in fact it's more
almost 36 hours now that Columbus been
sitting out on her and do you hope that
Tandy does come and arrive at some point
all right now it sounds like James is
busy with his infrared at the moment and
sydnee's I think still making his way
towards Chad I see you stuck with us in
our sleepy leopard who is taking it very
very easy at the moment I actually think
Sydney should have just joined Jamie
this afternoon because he's also had a
fairly easy afternoon of it and taking
it very easy Craig's laughing at the
back yeah and two of them the two of
them other TV stars for surfing I expect
lots of things from them this evening
meandering TV and how free they've
enjoyed having a nice sort of relaxing
break I I know though that obviously we
were joking around but Jamie being a TV
star not wanting to the Internet job of
course that's absolute nonsense
it's that [ __ ] is broken so Giggy has
got an internal cut bearing issue which
is not ideal and so she's decided to
just retired you go for the afternoon
until such time as the TV show try to
get it through the TV show and then
Chico will be decommissioned tomorrow
for two days as the gearbox gets hauled
out and the internal clutch bearing gets
changed by our master mechanic oppa and
so that's what's going to happen to
Jacob I'm supposed gigi is getting all
that these things do happen from time to
time and unfortunately you will see kind
of these changes and make cars I mean on
in and you know rusty was in the doctor
for a while so I suppose it is only fair
that Chico goes and gets a little bit of
a kind of look off dish she's an old
lady now his Jigar been around for quite
some time and has had a tough life and
me it's Rex it's been gonna see driven
around by civilians which was never easy
for any card I think even rusty and
Wendy a certainly bore the brunt of our
driving Oh delightful yes now it sounds
like the host of this show and that His
Majesty Jay Sir James Henry has powdered
his nose and powdered his head and is
now ready for us up in the Mara in order
to entertain you all as we kind of close
out to our afternoon and can only have
come from
tea Dix I suppose yes I've powdered my
nose and it feels powdery don't think
it's a particularly good way to keep
your nose no so it is and I'm not trying
to set up various night equipment much
of which I'm going to leave in the
wilderness right here it's a so
unspeakably useless that man who said
that you have to use this for TV shows
so I took his instruction I think enough
to know where this instruction comes
from I think I have Mike I have I have
an idea and well basically what I've
done is tied myself into about six or
seven feet of wire it's all over me now
and I I mean none of this is making a
picture of anything it's just here I
think we'll just go to the lines
Kirsten Astor's I sound like a diva well
you would too if you'd been tied
yourself in a knot with six feet of
useless wire anyway that's the sausage
tree pride lioness they did get up thing
that would where they'd come from now
almost as if they might go hunting but
then they didn't anymore there are so
distinctive looking in comparison with
the Kruger lions it really is amazing
whatever wound on her neck there
and for those of you who are perhaps a
little bit new to the show for me the
most obvious distinction is the fact
that they've got such big square boxy
ears with lots of hair on him Tristan I
think came up with a very nice theory as
to why they've got hairy ears and he
says he reckons it's - shut up you
useless implement it's to deal with the
the wind interestingly this female
doesn't have a very hairy year I can
hear some ground hornbills gang in the
distance you won't be able to hear them
for microphones he'll just definitely
make do with my impression they're off
oh that's gorgeous and they're pretty I
said that a lot today but really I think
I've been justified
just a little bit of silence see what we
can hear
last calls for Luther snipped luck
apparently you can't just hear the cause
of the ground hornbills came
well all I want to hear now is the
contact call of two lionesses of the
Cubs because that will then fill me with
greater joy than seeing lion cubs for a
while
I'd like to meet the new so Sasha's
chipolatas the mem Tyler that I look
like they want to show us anything other
than their skills at sleeping yes Maria
Dez is rather intimidating but most
impressive at the same time the way the
infrared reflects off the tapetum
lucidum at the back of the Lions eye
it's also quite interesting is when you
see them at a distance you can't
actually see their bodies just you can
get that sort of quintessential cartoon
picture if you like if they're so far
away that you can't that the infrared
doesn't pick up the body but you can
just see the eyes shining and it really
looks very eerie indeed definitely heard
something
maybe a lion far off to the south
I can't hear aligned myself though they
Sphinx ish the moment
since the slime
also remarkably this evening is that
it's still there's no wind and when it
does blow here quite a lot I mean I've
said this as a slight breeze comes up
but it often does blow up a storm at
this time of the day
she's going to sleep ah now many of you
asked me when our sabc show is it is
tonight the South African Broadcasting
Corporation on their third channel s ABC
3 this evening at 6:30 in a Central
African time that's 6:30 in South Africa
7:30 in Kenya where I'm sitting so I'm
just going to be an hour in front of
everybody today it's on the TV show and
then it goes for an hour until 8:30 our
time 7:30 South African time absolutely
useless just shouting at music beeping
useless we should just leave it here and
then he who wants us to use it can come
and fetch it in the morning yes enemy
were saying how silent it is in the Mara
well it's quite silent under this piece
of equipment that's been foisted on me
no I'm detached it I'll be giving it
back to monitor
grumpy old man you say please I tried
turning it off and on again I actually
did I did that three or four times and
it turned on and then it turned off
again each time there's a fault probably
be a fault with me but I'm not going to
try and seek that fault right now I'm
just going to place
what a lovely evening to be out Sunday
and the Masai Mara the entire reserve to
ourselves and nobody else about except
the saucers tree pride no I do hope
fervently that they're going to do
slightly more than they're doing now
then we have our TV show it's all very
well you know shooting the breeze as it
were with these lions and with you about
these lions but really when T becomes
we'd like them to perform slightly kuru
it's maybe a little bit of playing some
grooming and then some finding of baby
lions so that the audience can go as we
do I'm talking baby voices
and final controllers all talking in
baby voices when Jamie introduced you to
that tiny elephant today wonder if she's
got her makeup on Jamie likes Tim pinned
an extended period readying herself for
TV for TV shows Karstens just sit in my
ear mean classic white elk and
nothing of course is cuter than like
Cubs and have any luck we'll have some
of those I'll get up and go and get your
lion cubs to come on
flying high you say wouldn't it be fun
if the car battery died flying high in a
word no it wouldn't be fun if the car
battery died it wouldn't be fun because
well as you can well imagine be
difficult to push the car at this stage
here it'd be difficult to get somebody
down to us on account of the fact that
we don't actually have any cell phone
signals that to give them a pin it would
be hard no I don't think it would be fun
I did actually run the battery flat on
this very car a few nights ago I managed
to leave the light on and so when Pat
and Laurie got into it to start the
engine it was dead and I wanted to blame
everybody else but unfortunately had to
blame myself which hurt me deeply to the
core of my being anyway we've survived
here we are in the same car and the
lights off
now I don't know but money doesn't look
like to you she may have been suckling I
don't think she has just fairly swollen
she's also pregnant all right let's go
across the sitters who apparently has
now also about some Leone's I am just
here by the chitwa chitwa and we are
lucky to have the oklahoma's at the
moment they won't go home as the whole
pride is just lying down here so
fortunately we managed to get hold of
the big cats look at that this is an
incredible sighting so they are all
still living here at the moment but I
can see that the Sun is going down and
the temperature is cooling we might
start seeing some activities here very
shortly one two three four five six so
it's ten of them I can see the tree from
the Hmong Guinea pride as well as the
two four six seven from the koomer pride
you can see the among Guinea pride they
are trying to is trying to lick himself
is doing some self grooming
so these are one of those so that is one
of those endearing liens the one who is
having the problem with the mange which
is part of a skin disease transmitted by
some of the some of the mites so it's
kind of a parasite so I am very happy
that we got the Lions after such a very
long search
ii see they are very close to each other
so this helps in order to they warm them
the the main looks better by the young
males this mainly starts to grow when
they just about two years and that is
when they start to get chased away
because the main is coming down when the
main starting developed it starts to
irritate the dominant males in their
territories look at that none of the
young kuma is grooming the among any
lion you can see they are now starting
to stretch at the moment so I can't wait
to see what their plans are for this
evening and thank you very very much
it has been a fantastic afternoon and
thank you very very much for all your
questions and comments let's meet again
tomorrow